I'm going to tell you a story now of a man who was almost always alone, and he was courageous, tenacious, even an obstinate man.
In the face of his opponents, he was an example to us all, and his works equal some of the greatest explorers, but his name is less famous.
Robert Cavalier de La Salle was 25 when he saw Canada for the first time, and he was fascinated.
Here, adventure was waiting around every corner.
To answer this call to adventure, he abandoned the robes of the Jesuits.
Yes, he had become a Jesuit to please his father, but now his father was dead.
But on many occasions, he was to test the old saying,
who dares to abandon the company of Jesus
will be hounded with disaster throughout his whole life.
It was to become Montreal.
The Sulpician brothers have agricultural lands there
and large concessions will be granted.
A place called La Chine.
And they work very hard.
Conditions have changed a lot since Champlain's time.
Les Cabot's instruction was now bearing fruit.
Now they didn't have to wait anxiously for a boat from France to bring them food for their survival.
There were only a few thousand French, and here they were outnumbered three to one by the Dutch,
and twenty to one by the English.
In this colony's commercial interest, Peter Stuyvesant, the governor of Manhattan,
agreed to give the Mohawk Indians 400 rifles.
Allies of other tribes in the Iroquois nation,
they wasted no time in eliminating their rivals, the Hurons.
So the Hurons begged the French to help them,
To take them into their protection, as they had been promised, and at least to give them weapons.
But it was all in vain.
Before, the forces were just about equal between the tribes.
But now, well, those 400 Dutch rifles tipped the balance.
Coupled with the French refusal to help, the Hurons were crushed.
This destabilized the whole region.
The whole equilibrium of North America was like a house of cards.
The Dutch helped themselves to Swedish territory.
the English in turn took over the Dutch territories. The French kept their heads
down and stayed in their fortresses. About a hundred were killed or
disappeared. Meanwhile, the vicar of Rouen, a Sulpicien, and the vicar of Rome, a
Jesuit, were fighting for supremacy. The Jesuit, Monseigneur de Laval, who was to
emerge the winner, consecrated a bishop. He swiftly replaced the excellent
governor, who didn't happen to be a friend. The new one, Monseigneur de
Courcel and the Intendant Talon were excellent fellows and with them at last a real regiment of
a thousand men was formed. Now things would be different. These daughters of the king we're
waiting for are from excellent families, good breeding, often orphans. They'll make excellent
wives for you with royal dowries, of course. If you marry one of them, you will be given lands to
cultivate. You will prosper and the right to trade in skins, hunting and fishing rights.
We can use this ship and supply grain and vast quantities of fish to our territories off in the Antilles, where they are needed.
I know what I'm going to build and ride on the lakes, I hope.
Really? Ride on the lakes?
Yes, at first. Yes, but later on, if I can believe what the Indians say, it'll...
Huh? What?
Ah, splendid, my good friend, if that's what you want.
You have my permission to explore the West. I grant you a commission.
Mr. Colbert, sir.
Jesuits whose piety and zeal have done much for the people of this land have gone beyond the limits set down for them.
They will resort to any means to eliminate, to discredit anyone who is not of their opinion or one of their own.
You must therefore guarantee that no undue number exceeds the high posts in future,
but take care not to arouse Jesuit suspicion or appear that you are blaming them in any way never.
Signed, Colbert, King's Minister.
Monsieur, with your permission, I would present the brothers Marquette and Joliet.
They are experienced explorers.
They have been granted a mission to explore territories to the west
for the propagation of the faith and the glory of the king.
Well, it's July 1669, and here's the first expedition headed by the Cavalier de la Salle.
Two Sulpicians, the Abbe Galinet and Dolier are there, and some Indian friends.
And here they're sailing up the St. Lawrence and crossing Lake Ontario.
Mr. de la Salle, oh yes, a few days before you did, I went all the way to Lake Superior.
We have heard there is a copper mine there.
The governor ordered us to find it.
Listen, the Abbé Jolier has decided to go on all the way to Lake Erie.
We would quite like to accompany him.
We wondered if you would join us.
You could see I'm not well. I'm not able to follow you.
You had better go on without me.
Oh.
Both of them? Let's go.
Alone, exhausted, and with no food in a hostile land 2,000 kilometers from home.
He was to live on herbs and hunting and on handouts from Indians that he would meet occasionally.
and this continued for two years before he would return.
Do you know many men who would have endured that?
But he was a strong, hardy fellow de La Salle,
and early in 1672, two and a half years after his departure,
he returned to the lobby.
Frontenac, the new governor, arrived in Quebec.
He's a man of high qualities and a distinguished soldier,
loyal and brave.
It's certain that he and de La Salle would be pleased,
but not his enemies.
On your expeditions, you must go in force, excellency.
I know Indians well, sir.
You must impress them.
they are highly impressionable believe me right here is where i think we must construct our fort
i'll call it frontenac it will be the first permanent link in a chain which should mean
we can maintain french domination here sir my lad be on your way as we're going to build fort
frontenac and you work well go and prepare it for my visit very important that now and remember
to build a good road between ville marie and lachine it's really the best time for such a
journey you are aware your excellency a number of dutch vessels sailed from manhattan to attack
Quebec, your place is here along with your men, not going off on adventures.
Thank you for your opinion, Father de Blon. I will give the matter my consideration.
Sal has worked well. 200 Iroquois chiefs are assembled to meet us.
Two peoples can bring mutual friendship and prosperity together for centuries.
The 14th of France was hesitant about expanding to the west.
So de Lassalle, wanting to keep his options open, went to Paris for a private meeting with Colbert,
but a prior visitor had been the Jesuit Father Raguenot.
This young man is dangerous. To satisfy his ambition, he wouldn't hesitate to set one against the other of the tribes, yes, even to creating wars and massacres.
Then we shall have to find a way to pacify them.
This is most serious, what you've told me, and something has to be done.
He is quite mad. The man's a menace to anybody he meets.
It was a wicked thing to say. What made him do that?
The Jesuits wanted credit for most of the big discoveries being made, and that's why.
Some say they intended to join the Spanish down in the south.
And de La Salle, what happened to him?
Months went by, but he refused to see him.
However, one day, the Prince de Conte intervened on his behalf.
Don't you worry, believe me, he was to win right on down the line.
He would be commissioned to explore to the West,
and here authorized to build forts anywhere he thought it necessary,
and given all the men that he needed.
This is our route.
Eventually, we go into the Illinois River,
and then we sail to the Mississippi.
It's the truth, my lad, this ship's hauling some distance.
That's true, 3,000 kilometers.
And we'll construct our fortifications there, there, there,
And there.
Hey, what are you doing here?
I'm just building boats now.
Haven't I dealt fairly with you?
Didn't I give you a substantial advance on your salaries?
I want an explanation!
Of course, Matthew, he's going to explain it to you.
When we got to Krebker, they told us it was crazy trying to build boats here
and the Griffin would never make it this far
and we shouldn't try to stay here because those Indians were hostile
and we'd all be killed.
So we figured that the best thing that we could do was get away.
But all the other, the six others deserted,
took away a thousand pounds of supplies with them.
Now you tell me, who said that?
I can't really tell you who said it.
And in which direction did the deserters go?
He asked you which direction they took.
Come on, you answer, or I'll whittle your ears to points.
No, I thought you said, Marie.
It's my pleasure to go and capture all of them.
If you haven't come back and we're ready to sail,
you come and join us at Miamis.
Those are our trappers, gone over a year.
I hope that they bring in plenty of skins.
Next stop at Michilimackinac, understand?
You'll deliver everything that we can't take.
Once you've done that, go on to Fort Conti and unload the cargo.
Then you return as quickly as you can.
Yeah, you can trust me, sir. I'll carry out your orders to the letter.
Somehow I'm troubled by that pilot. I'm sure I've seen him before.
He reminds me of someone, but I can't place him. I mean, it's trouble.
The man is a good pilot, and I must do everything I can to protect the supplies.
We'll be needing them if we're going to succeed.
It's only a premonition, no more. Besides, it's your decision. You're the man who's in charge.
And it's to capture them.
I did run surters with some of their booty only. No sign of the boat. Just vanish off the lake.
Nah, I won't say I told you so, but nobody can go down to Mighty Chief's words.
Those who told you to counsel me, they all speak with forked tongue.
This night, I was not sleeping when Miami Monso came.
Yes, he along with all the others.
I know they brought you four cooking pots, eight hatchets, and twenty knives,
all of which you quickly buried.
They are presents of false friends.
Noble spirits speak in the light of day, as we do, not in the dark of night, hiding.
Are we enemies of our brothers, the Illinois?
Are we?
Do we come with weapons to make war on you?
No more cord or nails. Can't do anything without them.
I'll go to Fort Frontenac and see what's going on.
I'll return with reinforcements and supplies.
Going in winter, you'd have to be crazy to try it.
Don't worry, I'm used to doing it.
You will guard the fort at Crevcourt until I come back.
And then our friends set off on an imbecilic journey once again,
2,000 kilometers, but this time with a handful of men.
If I told you every adventure they had, we'd be here till past midnight.
And maybe even till dawn.
Anyway, finally arriving, you can imagine in what state, arriving at Fort Frontenac,
Tonti's news reached his ears.
Meanwhile, when the cat's away, the mice will play,
and a revolt breaks out at Creve Coeur, and there seems to be somebody behind it.
Oh.
Some deserters have been spotted at Lake Ontario.
It looks like they went that way. After them!
What is my witness? Is this a sign to the bottom?
Yeah, and the cargo. Where is that?
It was sheared out. That was the bargain.
What?
In a word, returning to Creve Coeur on January 25, 1681,
One, the Cavalier de la Salle, together with his small band, embarked on the great voyage of their lives.
Finding the Mississippi, there were 22 Frenchmen, 18 Indian men, 10 Indian women, and even three children.
Hey, wait! Wait! Wait for me!
Wait! Wait! Join up with it!
After after we reach the sea yet? No, just more the same.
Soldier, the ocean must be near.
His Majesty, Louis XIV, King of France and Navarre, hereby claim this land, Louisiana.
The brave explorer finally had a triumph.
It would be altogether too simple.
The trouble was, the new governor, a simpleton named Delabarre,
wrote to King Louis that all of Dassault's discoveries were useless.
He was kicked out of Canada.
Wasn't right.
Returning to Versailles, Robert did manage to convince the king
to name him governor of Louisiana.
Now, here he is with four ships and 300 volunteers
off to find the mouth of the Mississippi River and found a colony there.
He has under his command a certain ship's captain,
who was to be no help at all, Captain Beaujeu.
San Domingo will be a port of call. We'll unload the sick there.
Now then, set a course for Little Gold.
But that isn't what he said.
Do is he!
Do it!
Set a course for the west, otherwise the current will carry us too far east.
I would say the mouth ought to be right here. This is our course.
I still say you will drift too far east.
The best thing you can do, Captain, is button your lip.
You have already lost us one ship, and it was entirely your fault.
We're too far to the west, Captain. You will instantly order this ship to turn about.
You're here, Captain.
Captain, are you aware I have given you an order?
Just be a branch of the Delta, if you ask me.
Once again, de la Salle missed it, but one year after his departure and after endless searching,
he did discover the mouth of the Colorado River.
Over 500 kilometers west of the Mississippi.
Boy, de la Salle found his Mississippi and my missions.
There's a board, white anchor!
It's a hard voyage. We found the way up the Mississippi.
We'll go all the way up to Illinois, then come back down with reinforcements and plenty of supply.
Well, grant them your everlasting help, Lord.
Rule 1687, Robert de La Salle is assassinated together with two of his men, by one of his own bandits, said.
That was an awful way to end up.
You realize, one-third of the USA territory today was controlled by France?
What about the English?
Naturally, they didn't like it, and they outnumbered the French 20 to 1.
Yes, there would be the Battle of Fort Duquesne, where General Braddock would see his men drop like flies.
In the English offensive in Arcadia, the inhabitants were deported or shot.
That was called the great disturbance. Officially, France and England are not at war.
But this time it is war, and the English send their 30,000 soldiers to meet the French's 300.
Louisbourg falls, and Quebec is under siege.
General Wolfe manages to infiltrate his men onto the Plateau of Abraham.
Thought inaccessible, Wolfe, then Montcalm, defending a field, fall, and Quebec falls, and then Montreal.
Gives up Canada and Ohio to England, and for good measure, gives up Louisiana to Spain.
Oh, yes. And for 80 years, by the sheer willpower of the Cavalier de La Salle, it was French, but with Lafayette and Degrasse and Rochambeau, France was to accord these American revolutionaries the decisive help that resulted in the United States of America.